[موسيقى]
تقع مقاطعه خرسه الجنوبيه اوكرانيا في
موقع استراتيجي تطل منه على بحر ازوف
والاسود كما تقع قرب مصب نهر دنبرو
وبالتالي فهي تمثل خط امداد حيوي يبلغ عدد
سكان مقاطعه خرسون اكثر من مليون شخص
وتمتد على مساحه
28,000 و500 كم مربع تشكل جسرا بريا
لروسيا من اراضيها مرورا باقليم جمباز الى
شبه جزيره القرم التي تتصل بها وتتحكم
بمعظم مصادر مياه الشرب والزراعه التي
تغذي الخير تمتلك المدينه اكبر ميناء في
اوكرانيا لبناء السفن في البحر الاسود وهي
مركز الرئيسيون للشحن اضافه الى وجود
صناعات مهمه فيها مثل تكرير النفط
والمسجات القطنيه وغيرها عدا عن كونها من
اهم المناطق السياحيه في اوكرانيا في
بدايه اكتوبر الماضي صدقت موسكو على
اتفاقيه انضمام اضافه
روجيه الى روسيا الاتحاديه وقد عين بوتين
حاكما لكل منطقه من تلك المناطق من هنا
فانه قد ينعكس تحول موازين القوه لصالح
الاوكرانيين في خرسون على المشهد في
الجنوب الاوكراني
[موسيقى]